- People are wonderful.
They sometimes drift into
your life and cheer you up.
I was in an elevator in New York,
and two women started laughing,
proper, deep, (laughs obnoxiously).
I started laughing just
because they were laughing.
(crowd laughing)
I said, "What are we giggling at?"
This woman looked at me and went,
"Sugar, has anyone ever told ya
ya look like Ellen?"
And, oh my god (crowd laughs louder).
(laughs obnoxiously)
You
You've never heard laughter
like this (laughs obnoxiously)
I looked and was like, fuckin'
hell I look like Ellen.
(crowd laughs)
And that wasn't even the weirdest thing,
one of them started squeezing
her friends breasts.
Fifty years old, honking each other.
I've never gone more
instantly English in my life.
I genuinely said, out loud,
"what's going on here."
(uproarious crowd laughter)
It was like a monocle fell
down and toppled off a pony.
(crowd laughter)
Listen to her answer, still
squeezing her friends breast.
She just went, "it's her birthday."
What a world! (crowd laughter)
No man has got that excuse.
Imagine that mate.
You're down the pub,
just ticklin' your mate,
"'cause it's his birthday is why."
Darren, Darren, come over
and tickle Dave's spuds.
♪ For he's a jolly good fellow. ♪
I'd quite like to be a lady, you know.
When I was kid, me and
my brother used to play
a game called lady wrestling.
We stopped when we were 7
'cause dad said, and I quote,
"you're going to jail."
(crowd laughter)
Do you know what we used to do?
We use to tuck our
willies between our legs,
and have a fight, and that was it.
(crowd laughter)
And the loser was the first
person who was tickled enough
that their willie fell out,
and they no longer resembled a woman.
I can still see my dad's
confused face, just
"what's that bloody noise,
I'll deal with it, NO!
Fucking hell!"
(crowd laughter)
Morning!
Get your dick out of your
ass and get ready for school.
Yeah, you'd like that wouldn't you?
STOP!
(crowd laughter and clapping)
But I would.
I'd like to be a lady, it's the kindness
that women show when you're drunk.
You're lovely to each other.
I was on the Tube recently,
there's a load of girls
all a bit of pissed.
One of the girls got
stuck in the Tube door.
None of her friends laughed, none of them.
Oh, Sarah.
They rescued her.
Started stroking her hair.
I was scared girl, I was scared.
If that was a man, he'd still
be on the fucking Underground.
Lads, seriously, it's
moving now. (Sheep noise)
Say hello to the Facebook you fat fuck.
(crowd laughter)
You're gonna die.
Tickle his balls, tickle his balls.
That's what happens, innit.
If one of your friends passes
out, you don't look after him.
Your weirdest mate will go
up to him, get his balls out,
and pop them on his head or in his mouth.
Do you ring the police, No.
You take picture after picture.
No woman has that story, that's
why you're better than us.
You've never made that call.
Gotta go Steve, the usual's happening.
Sarah's out cold and Linda's
rubbin' her fanny on her face.
I gotta Snapchat this.
Get a good one Miriam, get a good one.
Hashtag mufflin'.
(crowd laughter)
Exactly!
Muffling, I've just invented a word
for a thing that will never happen.
(crowd laughter)